immediately reset so let's go ahead and
knock our pledge out of the way um so
representative B you want to lead us in
the
pledge okay I'm going to open up the
noticed executive session for the house
election law committee um we're going to
jump into recess um there's amendments
flying around we're missing two members
some members have to go to the bathroom
um so instead of trying to just Ram this
through uh we're going to come back at
9:30 um and uh and get our stuff and get
our stuff together so I will see you
guys at 9:30 if you need to use the
bathroom now is the time and we'll get
other two members time to show up so see
you guys at
9:30
okay uh we'll get going here um we're
going to start off with 1264 which is
the relative to
um excuse me got find it down here a lot
relative uh relative to the definition
of accessible voting systems um so the
committee is going to keep working on
this bill so we're going to recess it uh
I do believe we will have final product
next week would be my guess um yeah so
we're going to recess it we're not going
to take the vote today so I'm going to
open it and then close it um knock
1124 off the
docket relative to the
definitions 1264 yeah so with that 1264
is recessed it'll be noticed for next
week
um uh yes we I'll figure out the
date um okay so next up we will start
with opening up the executive session on
House Bill
1134 relative to inventory controls for
paper
ballots um representative Lane you're
recognized for a motion on
1134 I moved um it's inexpedient to
legislate is there representative Ward
seconds is there any discussion on the
motion of inexpedient to legislate to
House Bill
1134 no hearing none the clerk when she
is ready we'll call the role
representative B yes representative Pome
O'Brien yes representative quy yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative
Burnham yes representative
warry yes representative wood yes
representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rafter yes chairman Barry chair votes
yes and without the motion of in
expedient to legislate Carri is on a
motion of 200 is there any objection to
House Bill 1134 being placed on the
consent calendar seeing none house B
1134 we placed on the consent calendar
um
representative Lane who will be
responsible for the
reportative
Hamlet okay easy
peasy okay with that I'll close the
executive session on House Bill 1134 and
I will open up the executive session on
House Bill 1157 relative to over voted
and under voted ballots representative
Lane is recognized for a
motion I move to that this bill be
inexpedient to legisl is there a
second representative B seconds is there
any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate I'm sorry which bill number uh
we are on 1157 relative to over voted
and under voted ballots
hearing no discussion the clerk will
call the role in the motion of in
expedient to legisl and House Bill
1157 representative B yes representative
pom' Brien yes representative quy yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary no representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes represent
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative
hamr yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative RoR yes
chairman Barry chair votes yes with that
the motion of any exed to legisl House
Bill 1157 carries on a vote of 19 to1 is
there any objection to this bill being
placed on the consent calendar hearing
none the bill will be placed on consent
calendar representative Lane who will be
responsible for the committee
report I to ask same
thing yes but it's a motion of
itl okay I will put you down in the in
the interum I'll put it down on the
Green Sheet okay um with that we close
the executive session on House Bill
1157 we'll open up the executive session
on House Bill
1381 relative to required training on
Election procedures representative Lane
is mes is recognized for a
motion um I move to itl this bill is
there a second representative Ward
seconds is there any discussion on the
bill on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate seeing none the clerk will
call the role in the motion of
inexpedient to legisl to House Bill
1381 representative B yes representative
prom O'Brien yes representative quy yes
yes representative Ankerberg yes
representative
Burnham yes representative wary yes
representative wood yes representative
Osborne yes representative kutab yes
representative restive Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
HR yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yeah representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative ra yes
chairman Barry chair votes yes with the
motion of any speed to legislate carries
on a vote of 20 to Zer is there any
objection to House Bill 1381 being
placed on the consent calendar seeing
none um House Bill 1381 will be placed
on the consent calendar representative
Lane you want to uh get back to me on
who's going to do the committee report
I'm put you down in the interum all
right with that we will close the
executive session on House Bill
1381 we will open the executive session
on House
Bill
1523 uh which I will recess we may call
this back later today I'm just going to
recess it for right now um which one was
it 13
um so next up will be we just did 1381
sorry just crossing things off my list
here all right next up we will open up
the executive session on House Bill
1200 um which is relative to controll
and secured storage of printed ballots
representative Lane is recognized for a
motion why are you because you're the
ranking
member
I move to itl this bill a motion of
inexpedient to legislate is there a
second representative Brennan seconds is
there any discussion on the motion of in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1200 seeing no discussion The Madam
clerk will call the role when she is
ready representative fo yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative quy yes representative
inberg yes representative Burnham no
Representative warry no representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane yes representative uh Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion of in carries on V of
18 to two is there any objection this
bill being placed on the consent
calendar hearing no objection the bill
will be placed on the consent calendar
as in expedient to legislate
representative Lane you'll get me a
committee
report yes sir thank you um going to
close the executive session on House
Bill
1200 scratch this
off all right
cruin
okay
all right we'll uh start we'll open up
the executive session on House Bill 1133
relative to enabling you aava voters to
email back completed ballots uh I will
make a motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1133 is there a second representative
Lane seconds is there any discussion on
the motion representative Brennan is
recognized thank you Mr chair um I'm
just wondering if the committee might um
if the committee has considered
potentially a motion of interm study for
such a bill um given that we recognize
the importance of yava Voters getting
their ballots back in time and perhaps
that might be appropriate for um showing
good faith to look into uh um a secure
return of those ballots
electronically representative B yeah
thank you Mr chairman uh interim study
or itl I mean people can still work on
it and come up with another bill next
year it's you know if they want to you
can meet on your own with other people
and come up with a bill it's just that
interim study requires us as the
committee to get together and come up
with something but it still kills the
bill and and nothing prevents anybody
from coming up next year with a similar
bill with change as you want
so further
discussion seeing none the clerk call
the role on the motion of inexpedient to
legislated on House Bill
1133 representative fo yes
representative Poma Brian yes
representative quae yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Osborne yes representative cutab yes
representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry uh chair votes
yes and with that the motion of any
speeding to legislate carries on a vote
of 20 to zero without objection this
will be placed on the consent calendar
um I will take care of the committee
report so the committee knows I will
write a report that says the committee
is interested in this um but is has
security concerns um so it will not be a
it will not be
a um
total um rebuttal of the idea thank you
um
with that I will close uh the executive
session on House Bill
1133 scratch it off my list there we go
um and oh here we go this will be a fun
one uh we'll do I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill 1313
relative to access to the voter
checklist by candidates and I will
recognize um representative Burnham for
a
motion House Bill
yes I would like to make a motion ought
to pass and I believe there was an
amendment to that we have to have a
second to the motion of ought to pass
which I think representative Howard
wants to do I'll second representative
Howard seconds um is there another
motion anyone like to bring any
amendments forward yes uh I would like
to move uh Amendment
0624 uh to Amendment H or to HB
13 this would uh ensure that we could
actually still email the uh copy of the
checklist to people who request it in
spreadsheet format which is uh currently
unavailable uh giving them two free
requests per election meaning that if
they're running for say a local town
office they can request it twice then uh
in case you know one copy is uh damaged
or lost uh and they can then request two
more copies if they're running for say
state
representative uh after that point towns
May charge a fee up to $25 as is the
current uh pricing system for these uh
checklists uh so this just kind of
enables us to have electronic formats
available uh so that we can do so in a
manner that prevents uh any abuse of the
system uh that pretty much summarizes it
uh and I hope that you support the
amendment thank
you okay
um got we we do a motion here so we've
we've brought forward Amendment
d026
0624 and I believe representative
Burnham seconded that Amendment right
yes I did there we go we got a little
ahead of ourselves we were just on
discussion on the amendment is there any
further discussion on the
amendment seeing none uh the clerk will
call R we are voting on the amendment
we're not voting on the bill we're
voting on Amendment 2024 ja0
0624 representative B yes representative
Pome O'Brien yes representative quy yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
lean yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad
yeah representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative raer yes
chairman Barry chair votes yes that the
amendment carries on a vote of 20 to
zero representative Burnham is now
recognized to make a new
motion yes I'd like to make a motion to
ought to pass with the amendment
representative bur makes a motion on
House Bill 1313 for ought to pass
Amendment with Amendment 202 24-
0624 representative Howard I believe is
seconding that motion power second that
motion we're now on discussion of the
bill as amended is there discussion on
the bill as
amended seeing none the clerk call the
role on the motion of op to passes
Amendment on House Bill 13313 with
Amendment 202 24-0 624h representative
Bo yes representative prom Brian yes
representative quy yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative
wary yes representative wood yes
representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
Lane
yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion of octop pass as
amended carries on a vote of 20 to zero
is there any objection to this bill
being placed on the consent calendar
hearing none the bill will be placed on
the consent calendar representative
Burnham you'll be responsible for the
committee uh for the committee
report okay um all right and with that
we'll close
the uh executive session on House Bill
and
um I don't have the amendment yet so we
can't do it
um we have it is everybody here we at
full strength yep okay um okay let's uh
well let's just let's just get this one
out of the way um I'm going to open up
the executive session on House Bill
1569 um I will make a motion of ought to
pass representative Aken Berg's seconds
their discussion on House Bill
1569 motion of about to pass
representative Brendon is recognized
thank you Mr chair I just want to remind
the committee of the
testimony that
highlighted that this bill trusts the
Challenger more than it trusts the voter
who is trying to exercise their right to
vote and I think that is problematic
with this bill and I would urge my
colleagues to vote no on the ought to
pass
motion there further discussion on the
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
1569 representative Lanes
recognized thank you Mr chair I I would
also just remind everybody that um
there's an affidavit for uh
proving there is currently an affidavit
for proving that you are a US citizen
this removes that which um we heard in
testimony is probably
unconstitutional so I would raise that
issue and I think we also uh recently
received an email all of us on the
committee uh questioning uh how it might
um take us out of uh some it's it's
against Federal statutes both Hava and I
think it's the um right to vote act so I
would just raise those and say that
maybe we need a little more work to
study this um before we uh vote
ourselves into what probably will be a
very large
lawsuit further discussion on the motion
of ought to pass um
with that the clerk will call the role
on the motion of ought to pass on House
Bill 1569 representative Bo yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane no representative Ward no
representative Hammer no representative
no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative
Brennan no representative Grill no
representative Howard no Representative
rter no chairman Barry chair votes yes
that the motion of ought to pass fails
on a vote of 10 to 10 representative
Lane is recognized for a second motion I
move that um the bill be um
ited representative M excuse me
representative Lane makes a motion of
inexpedient to legisl on house B 1569 I
believe representative HR was the second
did I hear that right okay uh with that
we are on the motion of uh inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 1569 is there
a discussion on the
motion um I'll make one discussion I'll
be voting against the motion of in
expedience legislate voter ID is very
popular um we've made some strides in
moving away from the ridiculous system
of showing up Boy Scout honoring your
way to a ballot um the recent Associated
Press poll showed that even 50% of
registered Democrats support voter ID um
this Bill gets us closer to voter ID
which I know members will dis disagree
with um but I think it's very reasonable
that if you're showing up to vote that
you carry a basic form of ID most people
drive to the polls you need an ID to buy
cold medicine you need an ID to get on a
train you need an ID to get onto a plane
um you need an ID to do basically
everything except for cast about in the
state of New Hampshire um so with that I
will be opposing the motion of 1569 I'm
sure someone will have a rebuttal but I
won't be speaking to it
again yes representative
plan I I couldn't resists so um I would
remind you that the reason that we have
the same day affidavits is because we
have a um we've been excused for lack of
a better term from the Motor Voter Rule
and that's why we have same day
affidavits if we go this route we will
lose that exemption and we will need to
do all the requirements of Motor Voter
and at the last time we talked about
this my recollection is that the
Department of Motor Vehicles said that
it would cost over a million dollars to
do
that yes represent quy thank you Mr
chairman I believe that in order to get
an accurate assessment of public
sentiment we do have to ensure we have
an obligation to ensure that all
qualified voters have the opportunity to
cast a ballot however we are equally
obligated to ensure that only qualified
voters get to cast a ballot so that we
can prevent delution of of the franchise
for those qualified
voters so I am going to vote no on this
thank
you further discussion on the bill
representative Brennan thank you Mr
chair I will remind the committee that
there is no widespread voter fraud and
voters that show up to vote are
qualified voters this bill would allow
affidavits for challenging the
voter um but does not allow affidavit
for the voter themselves and again is
trusting the Challenger more than the
voter trying to exercise their right to
vote it still maintains affidavits just
not for the voter themselves only for
the people that are trying to stop them
from voting this is a barrier to
exercising again the right to vote we've
also heard testimony about um the
housing crisis here in New Hampshire
we've heard testimony about individuals
suffering um extreme circumstances where
their home has burned down and they did
not have the
appropriate um identification that's
laid out in this bill but nonetheless
still has the right to
exercise uh still has the right to vote
and so again for all of these reasons I
would urge my colleagues to vote
itl any further discussion on the motion
of inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill 1569 seeing none Madame clerk will
call the role on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate uh
representative Bo no representative pom
O'Brien no Representative quae no
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham no Representative
warry no representative wood no
representative Osborne no Representative
kutab no representative lean yes
representative Ward yes yes
representative Hammer yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry uh chair votes
no uh with that the motion any spee to
legislate fails on on a vote of 10 to 10
um the bill will be reported out without
recommendation um representative qua
will you please do the report for the
motion of ought to pass um and
representative Lane will you get me an
individ I think representative Howard
will be doing that representative Howard
okay okay with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill
um let's go back to the
list oh we can knock this one out um
going to open up the executive session
on cacr 19 relating to redistricting
providing that independent redistricting
commission shall be established to draw
boundaries for state and federal
Offices um representative oh I'm that's
me I'm going to make a motion of
inexpedient to legislate is there a
second I second it representative qua
seconds my long hanging motion of yes Mr
chair there's an amendment that's coming
to
this so I ask that we can I will
withdraw my motion of uh itl do you know
when the will be it's done I've just
asked for it to be printed before noon
so we'll come back we'll come back to it
um I will withdraw a motion so there
will be no there will be no motion and
it and it's technical the same the
amendment is to change the um the where
it says the year ending in one it
changes it to zero and then it it uh
correctly sets forth how the commission
votes that's fine
um okay uh that we will
recess cacr 19 and we will go
into um we're going to go into going to
open the executive session for House
Bill
1098 relative to ballots delivered to
Elder Care Facilities uh I will make a
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
1098 is there a second I second that
representative Pam O'Brien seconds um
I'll speak very briefly to this bill um
this bill is just authorizing language
it's not a mandate it's not a
requirement um I actually think it's
more appropriate that the clerk their
Deputy handles these um when possible so
I have no problem with authorizing
language it's not a mandate um so that's
why I'll be supporting it if if it was a
mandate I would probably oppose it um
but it's not it just allows it and says
that they can do it so with that I'm I'm
fine passing it um so that's my motion
of ought to pass on
on uh House Bill 1098 is there any
discussion further discussion on the
bill seeing none the clerk will call the
role on the motion of ought to pass on
House Bill
1098 representative B yes representative
pom O Brien yes representative qua yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
lean no no representative Ward no
Representative hamr no representative
Hamlet no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative
Brennan no representative Grill no
representative Howard no Representative
rter no chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion of octop pass fails
representative Lane is recognized for
another motion I move that this bill be
um an expedient to legislate is there a
second representative board seconds
there discussion on the motion of
inexpedient legisla House Bill
1098 comment I I I am voting um against
itl on this I I know that a lot of uh
nursing home staff appreciate more
guidance on this and this would
encourage that and I I think that's a
good
thing further discussion on the motion
of V spe to legislate on house B
1098 hearing none uh the clerk will call
the r motion legisl representative B no
representative Pome O'Brien no
Representative quae no Representative
inberg no representative Burnham no
Representative warry no representative
wood no representative Osborne nope
Representative kutab no representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative HR yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
RoR yes chairman Barry chair votes no uh
with that the motion of any speech
legisl fails on a voted 10 to 10 the
bill we reported out without
recommendation representative L will get
me a person for the report thank you a
second I have to on my sheet I have to
box it because there's two motions okay
all right I'm going to close the
executive session on House Bill
1098 scratch that off
um going to open the executive session
on House Bill 1310 relative to meetings
of Supervisors of the
checklist uh representative prudom
O'Brien is recognized for a motion I
move a to pass a motion of a to pass is
there a
second second representative Wy second
the motion of ought to pass on House
Bill 1310 is there discussion on the
bill on the motion
rather yes yes sorry thank you you you
got to hold I've got two people leing I
get higher than Lane okay that's my
goal this bill requires uh the
supervisors of the checklist to meet
more often and I don't think it's it's
it's an honorous request I think that's
this is doable and I think this is a
good
thing further
discussion represent of Lane yes you got
you got to hold your so the the clerk in
her diligence leans forwards to write
her notes so I can't see you guys to my
left so you got to really fire that hand
out
um so um I'll be voting against um um
OTP and the main reason is that a lot of
Clerks and supervisors already do this
but particularly in the smaller towns
and the rural areas um they don't have
the Staffing or um they don't need to do
this because they only have thousand
voters at the most so um for that reason
um I'll be voting against um a to
pass further discussion on the motion of
a to pass on house B
1310 hearing none the clerk will call
the mo the the role representative B yes
representative proma Brian yes
representative quy yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative uh Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane
no representative Ward no representative
HR no representative Hamlet no
representative Mirad no representative
Bay no representative Brennan no
representative Grill no representative
Howard no representative rafter no
repres uh chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion of ought to pass
fails on a vot on a vote of 10 to 10
representative Lane is recognized for a
motion I uh move that the uh Bill be
voted in expedient to legislate
second representative hyr seconds their
discussion on the motion to V speed to
legis House Bill
13:10 hearing none Madam cler call the
rooll representative
B no representative Pome O'Brien no
representative qua no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham no
representative wary no representative
wood no representative Osborne no
Representative kab no representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes repes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rter yes
chairman Barry chair votes no uh with
that the motion of ined to legislate
fails on a vote of 10 to1 uh this bill
will be reported out as without
recommendation representative Lane
you'll get me a report from someone or
somebody give me a report uh and
representative weie can you handle the
report on this one
yeah okay that close the executive
session on on House Bill
1310 and we will open excuse me open
up the executive session on oh yes uh
House Bill 1557 uh requiring the
secretary of state to enter into a
membership agreement with the electronic
registration information Center um
representative katab is recognized for a
motion I move itl motion of V speed to
legislated on House Bill 1552 I will
second that motion um representative
katab would you like to speak to your
motion briefly I just have concerns you
know with with uh this being a violation
of article 2B and an individual's right
to privacy all of this data is going to
be shared and I'm not sure that it's
constitutional to do so thank you there
further discussion on the yes PR Brian
thank you uh I had concerns about this
being an organization that is not
completely transparent they have an
office but who knows where it is because
they're concerned about their privacy
all of this data that's being collected
is this a data
mining SK situation what is this for
this is I'm concerned about that and my
and I will be voting against it
reprentative bone thank you um yeah I
did some research on this and my big
question is if this is so good why are
states leaving and it's also some some
concern that this is a George Soros
organization I hav improved one way or
another but just by the purpose of
States leaving why are they leaving if
so good thank
you further discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate representative
Brennan thank you Mr chair just to
respond to um my colleagues arguments
and suppor of in expedience to legislate
uh this is not a constitutional
violation um we cannot hold
that part of our
constitution uh and pick and choose when
to apply that part of our constitution
so to try and claim that there is a
right to privacy in our constitution for
the data that is hashed so that it can't
be hacked and not claim that there is a
right to privacy for so many other
things that are dealt with on the house
floor and in many other committees is
hypocritical and I I'm appalled that we
would be using that to as an
argument to stop something that would
benefit our election officials that
would increase the accuracy of our voter
roles increase
efficiency and make sure that no one is
is voting in more than one location
which I am aware that there are many
people on this committee who have those
concerns and we have seen many bills
that try to address those concerns that
make it more difficult for people to
vote this bill does not make it more
difficult for people to vote but it does
allow for checking for fraudulent
activity in voting and make sure that we
don't have
duplicative uh voters whether it is in
any of our neighboring states that are
also members of Eric um or whether it is
in towns within our state this is a
proven secure reliable system it is run
by the member states not by a shady
organization I take issue with the
mention of George Soros being being a
reason to reject this bill that is
frankly anti-semitic rhetoric and I will
not accept that argument I'm going to
the member's out of order for that um
that you can challenge the ruling of the
chair we're not going to be we're not
going to be that's
inappropriate so you you may continue
but do not Levy out do not Levy
allegations like that it's inappropriate
my apologies Mr chair I I apologize I I
do take offense I apolog oliz for taking
offense but uh I do so
regardless um this is a proven
bipartisan system I'm I'm sad that there
are members on this committee that don't
recognize that it is bipartisan there
are many states that have pulled out in
the recent in recent years that are now
looking to join back in there are at
least six states that are in the process
of joining so while there may have been
uh The Exodus of nine Republican states
in the past some of those are indeed
looking to get back in and I would urge
the committee to recognize the
bipartisan uh organization the
bipartisan state run member state run
organization that can improve our voter
roles thank you further comments on the
motion of expedient to legislate on
House Bill
1557 hearing none the clerk will call
the role representative
Bo no I mean Excuse me yes
representative PR o' Brian yes
representative quae yes representative
inber yes representative wey oh
representative Bram sorry yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane no representative board no
Representative hamr no representative
Hamlet no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative
Brennan no representative Grill no
representative Howard no representative
rafter no chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion any exped of
legislate fails on a vote of 10 to 10
representative Lane is recognized for
another
motion I vote that the bill be ought to
pass is there a second on the motion of
ought to pass on House Bill 1557
representative seconds is there any
discussion on the motion of ought to
pass
um no okay yes representative Brenan I
will just once again remind the
committee that this is a bipartison
member state run organization that
increases the accuracy of our voter
roles make sure that there is no
duplicative voting that supports our
election workers it is is the only
proven reliable secure data system to
ensure what we all want which is safe
secure and efficient elections with no
voter
fraud thank you and I would urge all to
pass further discussion on the motion of
ought to pass um I'll give my quick
thoughts on this um I do believe this is
a violation of article 2B um I consider
my driver's license number I consider my
last four digits of my social security
number um I consider the fact that
government Warehouse is my birth date I
consider those three pieces of
informations together to be personally
identifying information um if this was a
federal contract you would need level 5c
clearance to handle that information um
so it is a violation uh I have I will
make the statement now if this bill ever
becomes law I will probably be one of
the first joiners of a lawsuit against
the state for giving my what I believe
is my private information to a third
party Eric is in fact a third party um
it does not matter that it is run by
member states it is a third party party
this is the state giving your
information albeit baby securely to a
third party that sharing of information
we would not allow for anything else um
so um I I will note we the committee did
receive a letter from member states
urging us to join Eric uh one of those
signers was a secretary of state of
Kentucky who just two weeks ago
announced that Kentucky will be leaving
Eric in a year so one of the members
that signed us encouraging us to join is
now revers course and is they themselves
in the process of leaving um so that
those are my thoughts um with that the
clerk will call the role on House Bill
on the motion of ought to pass on House
Bill 1557 representative bom no
representative Pome O'Brien no
representative qua no Representative
inberg no representative Burnham no
representative wey no representative
wood no representative Osborne nope
Representative kutab no representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Hammer yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
brenon yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry chair votes no
without the motion of oop pass fails on
a vote of 10 to 10 uh House Bill 1557
will be reported out without
recommendation um I imagine
representative Brennan you'll be
responsible for the report I can
probably guess that
one um okay I will close the executive
session on House Bill
1557 get this I will do a Minority
Report on that one oh thank you
representative kab I had you down but I
didn't say that thank you so much I I
apologize
had um
okay trying to see what else we have
with that doesn't need amending just
trying to go through here
11:46 uh we a reverse course on that so
we can take a votee on it um sure
um going to open up the executive
session on
1146 I will make a motion of ought to
pass um is there a
second I second representative katab
seconds the motion of ought to pass on
11:46 um I I don't want to beat this to
death um this bill is kind of personal
to me because I actually tried at one
point to get my name off the voter
checklist and you can't do it um so I
wish there was a cleaner less
controversial way um there are sometimes
very legitimate reasons people want off
the voter checklist um and um this kind
of prescribes that is it perfect I don't
know um but we need to start we need to
find a mechanism to make that happen
when a voter wants to do that um I do
have First Amendment concerns um with
forcing somebody to stay on the voter
checklist um I don't think those are as
strong as just I think you should have a
right to take your name off if you so
choose um can it be abused probably
definitely but I think you have a right
to get your name off there if you want
it off so um with that does anybody else
want to talk about this 1146 right yes
represent plan um I I will just raise
that the um Clerk's Association and the
Secretary of State are have reservations
severe reservations about this bill and
um it there's no limit on the time that
you can do this and if you really want
to get off the register then don't vote
for a couple years and it will go
off that
that that that period of voting would be
10 years uh provided that 10 years does
not fall within the last four years of
of a year that ins in zero
um it's okay um with are there any
further discussion on House Bill on the
motion of O to pass on House Bill
1146 all right yes representative board
sorry I just had one question I noticed
you can get yourself off the checklist
with an affidavit but you can't get on
it yeah yeah there you go
um any other further discussions on the
bill represent Hammer I just want to say
this is a simple Bill to abuse the
system thank
you further
discussion all right seeing none uh the
clerk Rec call the role on the motion of
ought to pass on House Bill 1146
representative fo yes representative
Poma Brian yes representative qua yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
Lane no representative Ward no
Representative hamr no representative
Hamlet no representative
Mirad no representative Bay no
representative Brennan no representative
Grill no representative empowered no
Representative rtor no repes uh chairman
Barry uh chair votes yes that the motion
of op to pass fails on vot attend 10
representative Lan is recognized for
another
motion I move that the bill be found
inexpedient to legislate is there a
second president hyr seconds any further
discussion on the motion of any expedent
to legisl on House Bill
1146 hearing none clerk will call the
role on the motion of ined to legislate
Representative brome no representative
Pome obrien no representative uh quae no
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham no Representative
warry no representative wood no
representative Osborne no Representative
kutab no representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
hamr yes representative Hamlet yes
representative
Mirad representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rter yes
chairman Barry chair votes no no with
that uh House
Bill excuse me House Bill 1146 report
out without recommendation I'll handle
the OTP report representative Lane to
get me an
itl yeah I think that was represent raor
wants to do that
okay all right I'm going to close the
executive session on House Bill
1146 okay
oh we missed one um okay we'll open up
the executive session on House Bill
1364 I'll recognize representative fo
for a
motion I move itl I will second the
motion of itl is there discussion on the
motion of any speed to legisl on House
Bill
1364 yep Mr chair we have an amendment
oh uh you do M um well I'll tell you
what let's take this itl vote we'll see
how it goes um I think I have an idea
and then we'll get since we're already
in that mode then we'll get to the
amendment de whatever works you Mr chair
fair enough we will we'll bring in the
moving forward I I get that sinking
suspicion um all right yes represented
bone yes uh the thing is I think what's
in here is the person's already breaking
law and you know so I don't think we
need another thing to say that breaking
the law so thank you further discussion
on the motion of any spe to legislate
hearing none the clerk with the RO on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill 1364 representative boom
yes representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative quae yes representative
inberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
lean no representative Ward no
representative HR no representative
Hamlet no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative
Brennan no representative Grill no
representative Howard no Representative
rapor no chairman
Barry chair votes yes filthy little pre
little presumptive there Madam
clerk um that's the motion of speed to
legislate fails um representative Lane
you recognized for a motion um I'd like
to have a motion of V to pass okay is
there a
second second representative BR seconds
are there any amendments yes yes do you
have uh y representative who wants to
move the amendment Mr chair I'd like to
move Amendment 2024
8908 which is an amendment to House Bill
1364 okay would you like to uh is there
a second represent restive Hamlet
seconds a motion for the amendment would
would like to speak to your motion
representative Bron yes please um this
amendment addresses all of the concerns
that were brought up during the hearing
um it has simplified the bill quite a
bit um it maintains that intent must be
proven by a
prosecutor um harmful intent which we
know is a high bar but I think it's
important to recognize that there are
people out there that will spread what
may be considered public
information with the intent to harm an
election official in fact we've heard
testimony that many election
officials um have received threats
against them it makes it harder to
recruit election workers um in a
contentious environment and divisive
environment this bill seeks and this
amendment seeks to
um deter the use of
doxing which would be revealing personal
information with the intent to um harm
the election worker and so I believe
that this amendment does make the bill
better and I would encourage everyone to
vote ought to pass on the amendment and
then otpa further discussion on the
amendment okay um I'm going to vote for
the amendment because we've always had a
long-standing agreement um where we
allow amendments even though we may have
veh disagreements with the underlying
bill um so I will be voting for the
amendment um but you can imagine giving
my vote of the previous motion uh where
I will be on the final
bill but with that the Madam clerk will
call the role on the amendment
2024-25 we are vote on the amendment
only representative Bo no
representative pom O'Brien yes
representative qua no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham no
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative gr yes
representative Howard yes representative
Rapter yes chairman Barry chair vot yes
um give give me a count on that one that
is 16 to4 that Amendment 2024
d89 0 carries on a vote of 16 to4 uh is
there a new motion that would like to be
made representative Lane is recognized
to make a new motion so i' like to move
um the bill as amended for ought to pass
as amended thank you okay uh we've got
an a motion of ought to passes amend on
house B 1364 Amendment 202 24-
08908 representative Brenan I believe is
seconding that motion we are now on
discussion on the bill as amended Is
there further discussion on the bill as
you have represent Brennan thank you Mr
chair I also want to highlight that this
bill
um is aiming to catch anybody
tampering with uh ballot counting
devices and this creates a penalty uh in
fact it is a Class B misdemeanor for
failing to comply with this section um
about tampering with ballot counting
devices which I know is also a priority
for some members in this committee and I
think that we all would want to prevent
tampering of ballot counting
devices so in addition to trying to
prevent um doxing of election workers
which we know is critical to uh our
elections being run efficiently as
always we they do such a good job but if
we don't have any election workers
available then our elections won't be
efficient so we need to do everything we
can to support them this bill supports
election workers holds people
accountable if there's any tampering I
would urge the committee to vote to pass
as amended
please fur the discussion on the bill as
amended um I will be voting against this
bill um there's parts of it that I like
I actually wish the tampering with an
election device was a felony not a clasy
misdemeanor um but the um the biggest
issue for me and it's it's it's an
unfortunate truth which is when somebody
becomes a clerk or a moderator they're
working an election they are a public
official there you give up some of that
right to privacy when that happens um um
my address is on the general Courts
website um it's on my campaign website
um it's just one of those things if
people want to find me they can um so
that's my one of my principal cons uh
objections to this is you know I I think
our poll workers I think bluntly I think
a lot of people have been acting very
inappropriately in the pulse um a lot of
people that happen to be sometimes from
my side of the aisle um and I don't it's
that's unacceptable um people need
to deescalate um this isn't the solution
to that problem I think um but that's
kind of my general statement is is part
of a core a core part of this country
and this state is a peaceful transition
of power part of that peaceful
transition of power is a peaceful voting
process people need to accept the
results of elections they cannot be
hotheaded in the polls um I appreciate
this bill for kind of what it's like its
idea um I just don't think it gets there
for me so I'll be voting against it uh
but I do appreciate it coming forward um
I do want to to I did want to say I do
think I do value our election workers
they do they are stepping up it is
getting harder and harder to do that job
it is getting more and more contentious
to do that job um and I I appreciate
where this bill was trying to go I just
it's just not ready it's not there for
me yet so further discussions on this
bill on the motion of ought to pass as
amended representative br
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your words and support of election
workers um and recognizing how difficult
it is for election workers um I just
want to point out
that the point of this bill while there
may be public information like a
person's home address um these are
largely
volunteers and if someone were to say on
social media so and so election work
lives at this address would hate to
see any harm come to them uh with the
intent of someone doing harm to that
election official this bill would hold
that person accountable and so I just
want to make clear that it is not a
matter of Simply sharing public
information it is with the intent to
cause harm to that election worker um
and that is a high bar for a prosecutor
to prove in court but I think this takes
a step in the right direction to
providing um protections that our
election officials and our election
workers need and I I hope that while it
maybe not perfect it is a step in the
right direction and I would urge our
colleagues to support the a to pass as
amended motion um for this step in the
right direction for protection our
election officials thank you further
discussion on the motion of op to passes
minut on house 136 4 hearing none The
Madam clerk call the role and the motion
to vot to pass as amended representative
B no representative pom O'Brien no
Representative quy no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham no
Representative warry no representative
wood no representative Osborne no
Representative kutab no representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman
Barry chair votes no that the motion V
to pass his Amendment fails on a vote of
10 to1 the bill will be reported out
without recommendation representative
bone can you handle the uh report of any
spee to legislate representative Brenan
Mirad Mirad Mirad a sponsor wow even
more reason to vote against not now I
feel much better about my
Al a little guilty there for a minute
but then I saw then uh we're going to
close the executive session on house
build
um do you have your Amendment for cacr
19 yet it's
ready okay so why don't we St in recess
for five minutes kind of collect our
stuff up we we're making pretty good
progress we've done 12 bills so we're
actually making pretty good progress so
we'll stand in recess we'll give you 10
get you up there um because I gu send
some emails too so we'll be back at 11
o'cl all right St recess till
uh oh I'm
sorry I want to read a procedural point
oh
um okay we're back um we're going to
start off off with one that I missed and
it was my fault we're going to open up
the executive session on House Bill 1384
relative to non- compliance by a town or
Ward moderator and Clerk and
representative Lane is recognized for a
motion on house B
I move that um this be found uh
inexpedient to
legislate representative Ward seconds is
there just uh I believe representative
weary wanted to speak to
this yes Mr chair thank you very much
just uh to clarify originally when as it
was originally proposed the bill sought
to kind of Remedy the
um what could be perceived as some gaps
if there was misconduct by uh uh clerks
or moderators and again I I want to
reiterate what I said in the testimony
there I do not think that is a uh
widespread problem at all I I think it's
actually the reverse that there are many
great moderators and clerks who
diligently perform their jobs but that
there are is a potential for a few bad
actors but um in um looking at the
rsas uh the infamous chapter 666 has
Provisions for the purity of Elections
and therefore I think for people who are
interested in pursuing um concerns about
non-compliance or other things they
should follow that where there is
Provisions for uh official malfeasance
and official misconduct for election
officials should that ever be the case
in our safe and secure elections here in
New
Hampshire okay further discussion on the
most expedient to legislate to House
Bill
1384 hearing none the clerk Madam clerk
call the role in the motion being speak
to legislate representative Bo yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative quy yes representative
inberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
represent kutab yes representative
lean yes representative Ward yes
representative HR yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Raptor yes chairman Barry chair votes
yes with that the motion spe LLY carries
on a votion of 20 to zero is there any
objection to this bill being placed on
the consent calendar hearing none House
Bill 1384 will be placed on the consent
calendar um representative Lane you'll
get me a person for that one okay thank
you with that we'll close the executive
session on House Bill
1384 representative Lane you ready to go
on cacr
19 okay I have withdrawn so we're
reopening um CAC r19 I've withdrawn my
motion of inexpedient to legislate
representative Lane is recognized for a
motion on House Bill C on CAC r19 excuse
me that on House
Bill yep I withw my motion oh okay I
would move ought to pass okay this's a
motion of a to pass on cac1 19 is there
a
second representative Brennan seconds is
there any amendments yes I have
Amendment uh 2024
d910 I've provided all of you a copy a
few minutes ago okay representative Lane
moves amendment
204-9129 is there a second
representative brenon second resentative
Lane would you like to speak to your
motion uh yes please um I've made two
changes to the bill that were brought to
my attention uh during public hearing uh
on the first page uh line 29 the word
zero uh it should have it was one and
now it's the year ending in
zero um otherwise uh you wouldn't be
able to do it to do the whole process in
time if it was a year ending in one and
then over on page three line 26 to 30
um I changed this to uh reflect
correctly reflect that at least seven
members of the commission with at least
one Democrat Republican and one
Undeclared member voting in favor of the
final plan when that's done the
commission certifies the final plan of
the Secretary of State and provides
copies to the speaker of the house and
the president of the Senate um before it
had been a carryover from the um uh the
uh stat the the previous bill that I
introduced that was a statute rather
than a constitutional amendment so those
are the two
changes I don't know why they redid the
whole
thing because got to support that North
Country paper
industry
um any further discussion on the
amendment
one8 hearing we are now on a vote on the
amendment just on the amendment the
clerk will call the role representative
B Sure yes representative prome O'Brien
yes Representative qualey no
representative Ankerberg representative
Burnham no Representative warry no
representative wood no representative
Osbourne Representative kutab no
representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Hammer yes representative
Hamlet yes yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rtor yes uh chairman Barry chair votes
yes on the am Amendment um 14 to six
that the amendment carries 14 to six
represent brenon you seconded that
Amendment correct all right sorry I
didn't write it down when I was going
off memory all right uh representative
Lane you like to make a new motion yes I
move ought to pass uh as amended um with
uh the amendment 2024
d910 so moved is there a second
representative bernon seconds we are now
on the motion of V to pass this
amendment on a house bill cacr 19 is
there discussion representative bones
recognize yeah I mean as with any R
districting like the word independent
redistrict commission one does not exist
anywhere also the only thing I would
like to see done on on elections and is
get the governor out of it but anyway so
I'll be voting no on this
bit further discussion CAC
r19 representative
Mirad the idea is not that the
commission is independent but that is
bipartisan thank
you
further further discussion on CAC the
motion of pass as amendment of CAC
r19 hearing none the clerk will call the
role on the motion of ought to pass as
amended representative B no
representative prom O'Brien no
Representative quy no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham no
representative wey no representative
wood no representative Osborne nope
Representative kutab no representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Hammer yes representative
Hamlet yes representative
Mirad
yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative raor yes
chairman Barry chair votes no with that
the motion of oop pass amend fails on a
vote of 10 to 10 I'll make the motion of
inexpedient to legislate from cacr 19 is
there a second oh sorry res of bom
seconds is there any discussion on the
motion of any speak to legislate I I was
going to make the joke this is where
I've got some things I'd like to say no
um seeing no discussion on the motion of
expedience to legislate for CAC The
Madam clerk will call the role
representative Bo yes representative
Pome O'Brien yes representative quy yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane no representative Ward no
representative Hammer no representative
Hamlet no representative Mirad
representative Bay no repres
representative Brennan no representative
uh Grill no representative Howard no
Representative rter no chairman Barry
chair votes yes without the motion to
legislate fails on a vote of 10 to1 um
this bill cacr 19 will be reported out
as without
recommendation um representative Lane
you have somebody to do the committee
report okay um
and I will take care of it I think I've
already written about this um copy paste
um with that we will close the executive
session on CAC r19 getting towards the
end
[Music]
um fact we might be at the end of things
that we're actually going to get done
today the committee will indulge me I'm
trying to get the trying to see if
they've printed the amendment to 1126
yet I did email it to the committee but
I haven't heard from them so let me send
it off to
Carrie you have okay all right
um we're going to open up the executive
session on house B 1348 relative to
polling places at which total balance
count exceed the total number of
registered voters um representative we
are recognized for a
motion yes I'd like to move out to pass
with the consideration that there will
be an amendment I imagine there will be
one is there a second I second
representative Burnham seconds
representative wey do you have an
amendment you'd like to present yes I do
uh it is amendment uh 2024
d894 okay give me just a second
uh representative weary moves amendment
20248 n4h to House Bill 1348 is there a
second representative Burnham I believe
a seconding yes I am thank you okay
representative weie would you like to
speak to the amendment yes as thank you
Mr chair as originally proposed the um
language in the original Bill talked
about negating the race and that sort of
thing and that seemed to be excessive
but the principle be behind it um a
situation where the total count of the
cast ballots exceeded the number of
registered voters seems to Warrant
further review when such an event occurs
so um this amendment changes it to the
um and moves it to the recount RSA where
if um the total count of cast ballots
were to exceed the number of registered
voters on the day of election for any
race um then the that person could
petition for a recount following the
normal uh Provisions for that and this
would be specific to um a candidate on
the ballot where this event occurred so
um even if that candidates race wasn't
necessarily directly affected at that
point if there was a uh odity or anomaly
where uh the cast ballots exceeded
registered voters I think there should
be a provision for examining that a
little uh more closely so that's why
this amendment has been
offered further discussion on the
amendment representative
Hamlet um thank you Mr chairman so I
think it's actually impossible to have
the number of cast ballots exceed the
number of registered
voters um so if that did happen it would
definitely be an error and there should
definitely be a recap account which a
candidate could request anyway I don't
think we need this law to allow that so
my my rebuttal to that would be we do
actually limit who can request a recount
I believe
um
so yeah because it's not uh and I know I
know that's the case in primaries um
because that's been raised to me before
which was um somebody somebody actually
pointed out I think it was like less
than 1% or something like that they can
they actually cannot request a recount a
primary um so there it's I agree with
you in principle except it's not that
cut and dry um and I do think I do think
this bill accomplishes the objective of
if this I don't believe the situation
has ever occurred in New Hampshire thank
god
um uh yeah but if it did I I it it's
hard it's hard to vote against something
that if it did happen would be so absurd
that it would clearly an indication that
something went wrong whether it's
fraudulent or negligence or like
something obviously there's more ballots
cast in the registered voters like
something went wrong so U I think this
is actually
a a very
reasonable I don't say like middle
ground but solution to a something that
I pray to God is never actually a
problem representative Bal yeah it
hasn't happened in New Hampshire but it
has happened in other states some years
ago go in Washington state Kings count
Kings County which is Seattle even after
they did all the recounts and everything
else and it still came out that the
number of ballots cast was 10% more than
the registered voters in that county and
it just went by like it was I mean not
judge didn't rule that you had to do in
the reelection but it has happened in
other
states further discussion on the
amendment representative
Lane yes I I think I want to have time
to caucus on this because we just
received the amendment you know I'm
totally cool with that because that
gives me an opportunity to get my
Amendment till 26 uh how long do you
believe you will need rep BL no more
than 10 minutes all right we will come
back at
okay we're g to we're going to come back
um okay we were on the
discussion the amendment had been moved
in seconded if I recall so we're on
discussion of the
amendment um is there any further
discussion on the
amendment uh
hearing none the clerk will call the
role on the motion to adopt Amendment
2024 d
h representative Bo yes representative
pom o' Brien yes representative quy yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative
cutab representative
Lane representative Ward yes
representative HR
yes let me turn your mic back on I muted
somebody who was doing something
representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
B yes representative Brennan yes
representative K yes representative
Howard yes representative Raper yes rber
chair votes yes that the amendment is
adopted on a vote of 20 to Zer
representative we is now recognized for
a new
motion there's a motion of op to passes
amendment to House Bill 1348 with
Amendment 202 4-08 94h is there a second
representative Burnham is seconding yes
I am thank you all right with that we're
on discussion on the bill as amended on
the motion of ought to pass as amended
is there discussion on the motion of
ought to pass as
amended seeing none uh Madam clerk
you'll call the
role
yes
yes yes
yes bne yes representative kutab yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no Representative hamr no
representative Hamlet no representative
Mirad no representative Bay no
representative Brennan no representative
Grill no representative Howard no rapor
no chairman Barry chair votes
yes that the motion walk pass Amendment
fails on a vote of 10 to 10 represent
Lane is recognized for a motion I motion
that the bill be found inexpedient to
legislate is there second representative
Ward seconds we're now on discussion on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
to House Bill 1348 is there discussion
on the on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the
role representative Bo no representative
Pome O'Brien no Representative quae no
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham no Representative
warry no representative wood no
representative Osborne no Representative
cutab no representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
Hammer yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rter yes
chairman Barry chair votes no um with
that the motion exped to legislate fails
on a vote of 10 to 10 this bill house
bill 1348 will be reported out without
recommendation uh representative would
I'm going to give you the aop pass's
amended report uh because representative
where already has a couple um and then
uh representative Lane who you going to
give me for the inexpedient to legislate
representative W willing representative
W okay representative we do you do you
really want to write this one you look
like you
do okay you you're just looking at me
with a with a like I I want to write
this you have oh you already have one
more yeah you have you have
1310 all right um anyway I I'll give you
this one then 1348 um with that we're
going to close the executive session on
House Bill
1348 and we are going to open the
executive session on House Bill the long
awaited House Bill
1126 um I will make the motion of a to
actually we're already standing at a
disposition of a to pass because this
will was recessed so I will uh make a
motion I will move Amendment
202495 7h um is there a second
representative weie say bails me out
with a second um I'll speak to the
amendment uh this amendment is the same
Amendment you saw last week minus the
typo I think I hope um so if you could
please review it
um but I got rid of the cast ballot was
requested cast in um just requested in
so this opens it up to it's the same
it's the same as the bill that I
presented but it cleaned up the language
a little bit to be more precise I
believe addressing representative Ward's
concerns which were
legitimate um any dis further discussion
on the amendment hearing none the clerk
will call the
role representative boom yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative quy yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative hyr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
that the Amendment carries 20 to Z we
are now I will now make a motion of op
to pass as
amended uh for House Bill 1126 with
Amendment 202 24- 0957 is there a second
representative weary bailes me out again
um is there discussion on the motion of
op to pass as amended on House Bill
1126 hearing none the clerk will call
the
role representative Bo yes
representative pom O'Brien yes
representative quaale yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative uh bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Raptor yes chairman Barry chair votes
yes is that a fable 20 Zer you guys know
my names on that bill right no um
any uh is there any objection to that
bill being placed House Bill 1126 being
placed on the consent calendar hearing
none the bill will be placed on consent
calendar thank you committee members my
my long battle with the electronic
absentee Bist might be finally coming to
an end it's only taking four
years don't threaten me with a good
time for governor yes yeah then I'll be
up for governor don't you hear us an
open seat um going to close the
executive session on House Bill
1126 come back to my list
here
[Music]
um
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session for House Bill
1150 um recognize representative katab
for a
motion I am still waiting for the
amendment I know I'm just gonna we're
just going to open it up that's all I
need a motion I move out to pass okay
motion V to pass I'll second her motion
of L to pass I believe representative
katab we're now on discussion motion of
L to pass uh I believe representative
katab is getting an amendment for this
bill um representative kab I know we
don't have the amendment yet but would
like to describe what you are attempting
to do in the
amendment sure so basically the part
where it just says that everybody that
all the newspapers are required to give
a copy of their rates to the Secretary
of State I was just removing that line
because we've heard some off the Record
Rumblings that that's not so much
happening anyways um but we'd be leaving
the line where it it does state that you
know you can't charge one candidate
something different so that you couldn't
charge you know a republican more than a
Democrat or vice Versa for the
advertising rates we'd still be leaving
that line in there um so that's all the
amendment is looking to do and I should
have it very shortly yes I expect it to
be shortly but I wanted to have a
discussion on it before yes
representative Lane um I'm wondering if
we want to delay this and see if we want
to fold it
into six the 1091 Bill and that way it's
because we've been talking about doing
just that
correct so I I had that thought um and I
don't think it's entirely flawed logic
my my one thing that I my caveat that I
would add to that is if campaign Finance
form is a is a tough nut to crack to
begin with um and even if we get it out
of the house which is an if we're
working hard I think we will but it's an
if the Senate can do what the Senate
does um and I don't think that we should
let this okay go down on the hopes that
they'll pass the larger package but I I
do I had that that very thought did
cross my mind and I think it's a very
reasonable point of view um but I just
uh I just thought I've had I've had many
a bill go to the other side of the wall
to meet a swift a swift demise um so yes
that that is what representative katab
is suggesting does anybody do any the
members have any comments on that so
basically going to get rid of the
requirements that they report to the
Secretary of State their rates um which
I think is I I don't think that's
being I I don't think it's being overly
used right now um I also think the print
media industry
is already struggling enough as it is um
I don't think we need to have
a a a regulation like that uh the FCC
and the Fe do have provision
for um Equitable rates for broadcast
already so we are a little bit
duplicative in that
[Music]
um so but it does leave in the Clause
that you can't charge a differential
rate so I'm sorry yes represent um so
were you able to verify with the
secretary of state that they're not in
fact receiving
these I don't want to call anybody out
of the struggling media but there are
several who are currently not giving
such to the Secretary of State that
would be
correct yeah yeah and that's a
transparency thing which I I get um but
I just don't uh print media used to be
the pre the premier media um is no
longer um and I don't think uh I don't
think we need to over regulate them
there are
already they're already working hard as
it is so anyways uh when we get that
Amendment back we will uh we will adopt
we will I'm sorry we'll take a vote on
it but I wanted to at least have that
discussion does representative Lane do
you think You' be agreeable to that
concept I guess I want to read the yeah
you want to read read the amendment and
I may need to caucus with the group okay
but no initial oppos I I you reserve the
right to be opposed but no initial
opposition okay can I just make a quick
comment of course um just for some
background on the media industry for
most major networks um the rate cards
are already available um via the website
or you know reach out via email so even
if they're not being
reported by Common statute you can find
them pretty easily
yeah another point of concern for me for
this was with digital advertising um
some of them offer operate on an auction
based system a live auction system basis
basically real time auction system so
they have no ability to actually publish
the rate because it's changing literally
every second um so and as you guys know
I have said before I I really strive to
treat all mediums as closely as the same
as possible um because it reduces
confusion then you don't end up with 664
being 58 Pages um so anyways all right
so we will recess that we'll come back
[Music]
um and we'll try we're going to break
for lunch um we'll come back and we'll
do
1085 um 1523 if there's
agreement 1150 with Amendment and then
we will if we have time we'll discuss
1091 does that work for you
representative Lane am I missing
anything uh I have a lunch meeting that
goes till one so we'll have to be back
at one
anyways sorry to inconvenience for of
your head trying all right we'll see you
guys back at 1
o'
executive session on house B 1150 we
were in an octop pass stance um let's
introduce the amendment then we can
discuss the amendment um representative
katabi recognized for the purpose of
introduction of an
amendment thank you Mr chairman I'd like
to introduce Amendment 2024
d958 all right I'll second it
um as we described the question I think
I need to send to the clerk is the last
line 18 and
19 is erroneous look like it's just an
error from
OS um yeah I'm gonna message them right
now and just ask
um but she did say that the title need
to be replaced but I do see now up top
that it is also up there so let me just
send her a quick
email
yeah no that's the amended analysis
behind it that that's just analysis
that's not that's not that's not actual
verbiage um it just look like uh are you
did you are you sending them an email
right
now
actually yeah let me grab Christina or
Carrie and maybe they can offer some
insight we have a procedural question
here so we've got this
amendment and it looks like OSS just put
like a weird line at the very last like
they added to the end of the amendment
amend the title of the bill by replacing
with the following and there's nothing
after it like very clearly they just
forgot to delete it do we need a whole
new Amendment for that or or Os fix
that they'll fix it through an
enrollment
process
yeah yeah it's just a
typo
okay yeah I I think that that was my
understanding too is because they'll
operate like it's not up for debate like
that's clear that's supposed to be there
yeah space even between the period and
the a yeah so all right
um well see what else we
got no no they they changed the title of
the bill but they did that up top yeah
so it's it's just an erroneous extra
line that just needs to be deleted and
the question is is do we have to send it
back to LS get them to draft a new
amendment number or can they just fix
that and an enroll bills process and we
can just move on with our day I'm hoping
we can just move on with our day
um
uh I agree it
shouldn't did we uh did we receive our
re our researcher things seems to think
they'll fix that in the enrolled bills
process so they're going to fix it now
with the same number and they're going
to email it in a second so if we just
wait it'll be the same number if we just
wait to vote on it for one second until
they email us the corrected copy then
we'll have voted and they're okay to
correct it now now okay um so every we
have a great weekend and doing anything
fun uh I guess we'll stand in recess for
60 seconds and see if it comes
in
gonna we're going to come back in out of
recess uh the member has forwarded an
updated copy without the um erroneous
line in 18 and 19 um without objection
I'm going to say this is sufficient um
you can check your email to exactly what
I described it as um so we are still on
discussion on the amendment um without
the line the the erroneous line amend
the title of the bill by replacing it
with the following colon um so is there
further discussion on the
amendment okay seeing none the clerk
will call the role on Amendment
d958 H to House Bill 1150
representative
B yes representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative HR yes representative
Hamet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rafter yes uh chairman Barry chair votes
yes mon that the amendment carries on a
vote of 20 to zero representative katab
is going to make a motion of O to pass
as amended on 11 house 1150 with um
Amendment 20 202 24-9 58h I will second
the motion of ought to pass as amended
is there any discussion on the motion of
ought to pass as
amended okay hearing none the clerk will
call the
role representative Bo yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qualey yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Hammer yes representative
HL yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan oh representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
is that 19 19 to1 okay with that uh the
octop pass amended motion carries on a
voted 19 to1 is there any objection to
this being placed on the consent
calendar hearing no objection this will
be placed on the consent counter
representative katab can you be
responsible for the committee report yes
sir okay um so that was uh going to
close the executive session on house
1150 and I think we have one more we're
going to
do
um okay all right
um I think that's going to be it for
today we'll recess the rest of this and
go home
um well we have so left on the noticed
on the docket left for today is 1080
House of Bill
1085 House Bill
1523 and House Bill
1091 um I'm not sensing a large desire
to say and work on 1091 which is my game
plan um so with that I'm just going to
open and close and we're going to go
home this with without you have
something else you want 1085 that's
we're going to have to push it I think
because there's an amendment
um and I don't want I don't want to hang
around for another one um any
of right okay uh so I'm going to open up
the executive session on House Bill 1085
and recess it and then I'm going to open
up the executive session House Bill 1091
and recess it uh and I will open up the
executive session I've already done 1523
um okay with that I believe that
concludes our business for the day
thanks everybody um we'll see you uh we
will not be meeting on Tuesday we will
likely meet on on Monday um so probably
going to meet on Monday of next week and
that will be I'll probably do all votes
that day so we need to have basically
everything done okay right
1091 uh 1091 oh no we oh we'll try we'll
try uh Monday Monday Monday because we
cannot meet on Tuesday at what time Mr
probably 10: a.m. I haven't scheduled it
yet so you're going to notice I'm just
giving you a heads up I'm going to do
Monday I'm probably going to do 10 a.m.
but could be with is there a reason we
need to meet next week and not the
following week yes I I want to be done
with our business so the scheduling is
at my discretion so I'm I was just
asking all right I'll see you guys on
Monday
h